[Music]
there's allison can you explain what
internet is
an online network called internet and
what about this internet thing you know
anything about that
sure what what the hell is that exactly
the information super highway
the internet gave us a whole world of
exciting new possibilities
so i guess this is a story of how it
changed our lives
maybe it will yours too
and what an nft even is where did the
word fungible come from
i hadn't heard it until last week no no
idea now i hear it every day
all the time it's all i think about
nft's non-fungible tokens that's what it
stands for unable to be duplicated
replicated one-of-a-kind is this real
should we make should we be making five
million dollars i don't know
maybe nice but yeah like what is it
what's going on
what do president clinton conservative
radio personality rush limbaugh
and rock star billy idol have in common
they've all got electronic mail
addresses on computer systems linked to
the internet
the internet itself however is
definitely exploding
it hit and within like two years it just
it's become so
powerful if you ain't on the information
super highway baby
in 1981 only 213 computers were hooked
to the internet
as the new year begins an estimated two
and a half million computers will be on
the network
nfts of the future nfc of the future
digital assets this cap meme though
downloaded millions of times
sold for six hundred thousand dollars
the most expensive
nft ever sold and one of the 20 most
expensive works of art
period ever sold at auction the online
auction for people's the first five
thousand days just wrapped up at
christy's
final sale price 69.3 million dollars
that's more than most picassos monets or
warhol's
now to repeat that's 69 million dollars
for a digital token when a 95 000 banksy
was burned
and then resold it raised a staggering
400 000
as an nft jack dorsey turning his first
ever tweet into an nft which now has a
top bid of 2.5 million
nba highlight videos really taking the
lead with over 200 million dollars in
sales
180 000 this man spent on a i believe it
was a
zombie or no not a zombie right there
yeah
a week after a boom in nfts we may be
getting some insight into what's behind
these gigantic moves
the nft sales now topping a half a
trillion dollars
it's easy to criticize something you
don't fully understand which is my
position here a couple of months ago
there was like a big breakthrough
announcement that
on the internet or on some computer deal
they were going to broadcast
a baseball game you could listen to a
baseball game on your computer
and i just thought to myself does radio
ring a bell
you know what i mean
what how what am i missing here what do
i need
as time goes on people will wrap their
heads around it not sure people will
how how do you even buy these digital
items yeah it's an internet thing
complicated but yes my question is huh
no no but really what do you do with it
like if you have a digital file that you
paid 2.5 million dollars
yeah but then what if you can't hang it
up and then you show it to your friend
you know you're like here it is i have
it right here and they're like yeah me
too
and it looks the exact same every
business no matter how large
and no matter how small we'll be on the
internet in the year 2000. i think i
haven't felt like this since
web 2.0 2005. non-fungible tokens
are going to be a big part of all of
your lives i really believe that i think
this is a
space space like a real rail space and
so
the world of nfts today has some stark
similarities to the dot-com bubble of
the 90s to early 2000s
so the real question is is this a bubble
the short answer
yes it's my first piece white square is
now
going for 200 yes i have an offer for
200
on this masterpiece it is definitely a
bubble
but that's not the whole story so to me
this nft journey is amazing the
community is amazing i haven't felt like
this since
web 2.0 2005. the reason people care
about a blue check on instagram is the
same reason this is going to be huge
the nft space and tech space in general
is right for more innovation from new
startup entrepreneurs
and the best place to do it america sure
america has its problems but the
american startup ecosystem is still
second to none
because of all the startup
infrastructure venture capitalists
startup accelerators and just the sheer
network effect of having all these
startup veterans concentrated in one
place
collaborating with each other funding
each other sharing secrets with each
other
the problem is traditionally you would
have to physically move to america to
access all these benefits
but that is where first base dot io
comes in
first base helps you incorporate your us
company from anywhere
so that you can access the greatest
startup ecosystem in the world no matter
where you're at
you fill out a simple application and
they take care of everything
from filing the paperwork to opening up
a bank account for you you'll also get
over twenty thousand dollars in credits
and discounts
from their partners like aws brex which
is a banking solution i'm starting to
use
and more to help you grow faster twenty
thousand dollars that's pretty cool
first base has launched almost 5 000 us
companies for entrepreneurs and 160
countries and almost every us state
so whether you live in america europe
africa or really anywhere on the planet
first base makes it super easy to
incorporate remotely and access all the
great tools available to us companies
give your startup a head start by going
to firstbase.io and use code jt to get a
discount and white glove concierge
supports
that's firstbase.io with code jt with
the link below
[Music]
speculators are dumping money into
anything that has an nft
for the sake of it being an nft just
like how speculators were throwing money
at anything with a dot com in his name
hoping that it's gonna go up that
short-lived rush by investors to pump
money into anything with a dot-com in
its name
and mostly people are just foam mowing
into whatever people are posting on
twitter
there's no there's no evidence that it
has value there's no evidence that it
will hold value
they're like oh it's like a collectible
it's like crypto punks it's gonna
explode no no
how many collectibles can we possibly
have guys how many collectibles can we
possibly have
now some of these nfts do have the
potential to become actual collectibles
that go up in price
[Music]
but here's the thing real collectibles
like trading cards never start out at a
high price
they start low and gradually go up over
time there's a price history a legacy
behind the collectible and actual fan
base behind the collectible
but the majority of nfts today here's
speculation that start out at
astronomical prices
[Music]
and when you look at the buyers of these
expensive nfts what do you find
most were early crypto investors are
sitting on massive gains that they have
no idea what to do with
so instead of cashing out and having to
pay the tax man they transfer some of
their wealth into these nfts
there's a bunch of rich people going ah
yes i got nothing else to buy actually
yes they're called crypto whales and
they don't know what to do with their
money
if you want to buy something with all
your big gains that you've made in
cryptocurrency but you don't want to
sell the crypto because then you have to
pay the taxes on what you've made
this is the way to do it with nfts you
just
roll that wealth right into something
else that will also appreciate
i applaud them but there's only so many
of these whales around that can afford
these crazy prices
so yes this space is probably in a
bubble right now
but then the question becomes is it
gonna pop and if it does pop
are nfts here to stay do nfts even offer
any value that would make it last
or is it just a passing trend
[Music]
at first the idea of paying money for a
jpeg or video not owning the actual
rights to that content
that anyone else in the world can view
online right now sounds
pretty psychotic yet we're also the type
of creatures to pay sometimes an equally
psychotic amount of money
so that our shoes have a little check
mark on them so that our brick has the
worst supreme italicize on it
so that our instagram handle has a
little blue check mark next to it
so that our car has a prancing horse on
it even though we know
you'll never be able to fully utilize
all that extra horsepower on legal roads
so why do we buy
all these irrational things because of
one simple thing
status posturing bragging rights flexing
whatever you want to call it
we're social creatures we want others to
know that we have good tastes that were
high class socially relevant
so as i dug deeper nfts for art and
collectibles can actually have a lot of
merits
think about the bible collage that just
sold for 69.3 million dollars
making it the third most expensive
artwork sold by a living artist
this piece isn't just a piece of art
from an incredible artist
it's a culturally relevant artist that
millennials and gen z love
that a lot of your peers love an art
piece that happened to take people 13
years of blood
sweat and tears to make it means
something
people happens to be a digital artist
that's his medium
if you're a raving fan of people's work
you might really want to own a copy of
this piece
sure you can download it for free off of
his website but you and i both know that
it's just not the same
it's not authentic the same way wealthy
art collectors know that sure
they can just buy a fake copy of their
favorite painting save a ton of money
and hardly anyone would be the wiser
but it's just not the same as when you
own the original artwork that your
favorite artists laid their actual
hands on sure it's nice that i own a
copy of my favorite painting for the
backdrop of these videos
but i would for sure prefer owning the
original priceless copy that's on
display in germany
looking at it through this lens if you
won the auction knowing the notoriety
behind this artist knowing the story
behind this one of a kind piece
wouldn't you be at least a little proud
to own it even if it's all digital
and guess what people have been flexing
100 digital possessions for a while now
all you have to do is look at the game
grand theft auto gamers will spend an
ungodly amount of time
and real money in gta online just to
have the best most high class home
garage in
office just to show off just to have
virtual status
in a video game it's ridiculous now just
imagine the lengths people will go for
other digital assets but for real life
status
there are also a ton of other value adds
nft offers to artists
like how artists can get a percentage of
every sale that happens after they
initially
sell it since nfts give artists
royalties on
any future sale he's gonna make money if
this ever resells
there are plenty of other videos you can
go watch online that goes over these
other benefits
the only thing missing from this
equation right now is an elegant way to
display your artwork
to flex your nfts for the world to see
maybe it would be a section on your
instagram account
underneath your story highlights where
you can connect and display the art you
own
maybe a vr world maybe in-home displays
time will tell but once that happens nft
art will probably go completely
mainstream
i'm waiting to understand the
flexivization
of the nft and as soon as i understand
it
it's coming oh i'm the least confused of
all time
[Music]
another very interesting idea is
allowing creators youtubers and
influencers
to basically issue stock through an ipo
here's how it could work
if you believe that me and this channel
are gonna keep growing and if i believe
that i could grow faster if only i had
more money
i could issue a finite number of nft
jake trend shares
you would buy them hoping that the value
of these shares go up as the brand grows
and in exchange i could offer membership
perks like channels do with patreon
but for my shareholders and maybe even
dividend payments
and as the channel grows and the value
of your shares go up and you want to
cash out
you would sell it to the next guy that
wants these perks you profit from that
sale and i profit a small percentage of
that sale in all future sales as well
because that's what's coded into the
smart contracts
and if this becomes a thing you can bet
that the tran capital nft creator vc
fund will become a thing
where you can give me your money and i
will invest it in the up and coming
craters i see potential in
don't understand what i'm talking about
watch this video to learn more
and sign up for the inbox notification
squad with the link below
in case something like this happens in
the future just saying
the main hype around nfts right now is
for the art and creator world like we
just talked about
but i think the power of nfts extends
far beyond these industries
the main benefit of nfts that i see is
that it reduces the friction in buying
and selling assets
right now it makes buying digital art
frictionless for both the buyer and the
artists
in fact removing friction for customers
is pretty much the main thing silicon
valley does which makes them a ton of
money
taking friction out of products and
processes is the playbook of silicon
valley for the last decade or two
we're gonna take out tipping we're gonna
take out the need for you
to take out your credit card and do
payment it's just gonna be in your
wallet
which is why nfts are probably here to
stay because it does the same thing
and i can see the same logic being
applied to a lot more practical uses in
our everyday lives
nfts can maybe be used to trade real
world assets like homes cars and stocks
they can be used for documents like
birth certificates ids passports and a
ton more
so if you bought a sox nft you could
either redeem it for a pair of actual
socks
or trade it on the market or continue to
hold it while the price
ideally appreciates and sell or redeem
it when you're ready
so we are already seeing art
collectibles domains
gaming and virtual worlds i look at nfts
as being such a blank slate honestly
even beyond digital art
honestly you're gonna see this used for
a bunch of very sort of mundane
quote-unquote boring things it could be
like you buy a car you get an
nfp that sort of proves you own that car
and it's sort of tied to that car you
buy a house this
instead of a deed and this whole super
complicated process
we now go back through to sort of verify
ownership of a house
it's an nft boom that proves you own
this house with the dot-com bubble once
it bursted
the bad companies went under but the
internet and good companies stayed
like amazon and people like beepo gary
vee and mark cuban seem to think that
the same is going to happen here
the psychotic prices will eventually
boil over the last ones holding the bag
would be screwed
but nfts will live on there's gonna be
millions
of nfts projects and most won't succeed
it's it's so fun it's so new and it's so
exciting i think the uh
tokens with either a the most utility or
or have the most creativity are going to
rise to the top
it feels so inevitable that i think
there's a lot of hype right now again
the button's broken there's a lot of
hype so i think it's one of these things
we're going to get past that and you
kind of heard the last guest talk about
that as well
in the beginning of the internet there
was a lot of hype too and there was a
bubble and the bubble burst
but it didn't kill the internet when
tick-tock first came out
most of us were scratching our heads
tiny videos that you randomly scroll
through
of people lip singing and dancing it's
not really a thing
but today yeah it's just a tick-tock
that's what it is so maybe one day the
idea of non-fungible tokens the idea of
owning digital assets that anyone else
can view online
might just be as intuitive as the
internet is for us today
and just maybe we'll look back at videos
like this with the same arrogance of how
we look back at the old internet news
broadcast of the 90s
this idea of owning a file that's a very
foreign concept
but i think you know as time goes on
people will wrap their heads around it
internet is uh that massive computer
network
the one that's becoming really big now
what do you mean that's bad
how does one not what do you write to it
like mail no a lot of people use it and
communicate
i guess they can communicate with nbc
writers and producers allison
can you explain what internet is no she
can't say anything in 10 seconds or less
a lot of people are trying to connect
their coin base to their meta mask right
now
and they're like scared and i keep
making fun of them because i'm like you
made fun of your parents for not wanting
to put a credit card
into a website nine years ago and now
you're the boomer
yes that one fell down and i didn't have
time to fix it but we're gonna roll with
it so what do you guys think about nfts
let me know in the comments below
i was definitely really iffy myself on
them when i first started looking into
this
but they have grown on me so let me know
what you guys think below if you are
interested in business which obviously
you are
if you're watching this channel and
you're looking to launch your startup
first base dot io
is the place to do it all you have to do
is fill out their application on their
website and they will take care of
everything all the paperwork forming the
company opening up your bank account all
the stuff that i really despise doing
they do it all for you hands off so that
you can just focus on growing your
business and remember they also have
that twenty thousand dollars plus in
credits and discounts with their
partners so if you're interested click
the link below and use code jt to get a
discount and white glove concierge
service
if you are new to this channel we make
video essays just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
stuff
in the world of business just like this
video so make sure you subscribe because
it's free and you can dislike and
unsubscribe whenever you want
if you want behind the scenes stuff then
the live kind of stuff memes you can
follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io that is going to wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you